president gabriel bordich was keenly
aware of how much was riding on his
first state of the nation address
but it received an ovation when he
announced a national plan for finding
the bodies of thousands of people who
disappeared during chile's military
dictatorship
[Applause]
if we don't know where they are we
cannot heal our wounds
boric will also introduce a fiscal
reform plan to congress next month and a
long-awaited pension reform bill in
keeping with his social agenda he vowed
to build a quarter of a million public
houses
but the main focus was his road map for
addressing chile's most pressing
immediate problems from soaring
inflation aggravated by the war in
ukraine
to the escalating armed conflict with
indigenous mapuche groups it's been the
shortest of hunting moons for latin
america's youngest president whose new
left progressive program had awoken huge
expectations but in only 82 days a
combination of inexperience very bad
luck on the economic front and lack of
strong leadership to tackle violence and
rising crime have seen his approval
ratings plummet
borrich promised to increase the police
and intelligence budgets continue to
deploy the army and the rest of
haraocania region and allocate funds to
compensate those affected by sabotage
acts and organized crime
emulating his new zealand counterpart he
went further
i will introduce a law to congress to
totally prohibit the ownership of
firearms
we have seen what happens in other
countries and we won't allow that to
happen in chile
but the conservative opposition in
congress is unlikely to give boric a
break they thought that a new phase over
generation would make things easy but
it's never easy to govern and in boric's
case it's obvious
but it's recognized that mistakes have
been made but he insisted that he remain
optimistic reminding chileans that they
have a historic opportunity to build a
more equal society
lucia newman al jazeera valparaiso